bonjour 50 ans en Yvelines recrute si
vous êtes intéressé on est plusieurs
sociétés aujourd'hui regroupées ici de
50 ans en Yvelines alors moi pour ma
part je suis responsable d'une agence de
travail temporaire pour le groupe
adéquat
[Musique]
iques
c'est vraiment une première approche
pour nous présenter présenter les
sociétés sur Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
qui recherchent des profils et ensuite
si vraiment la personne en face de nous
est intéressée et si nous même le profil
le profil peut correspondre à ce qu'on
recherche on les convoque un entretien
plus poussé au sein de notre agence
c'est intéressant parce qu'on rencontre
directement à la population et on peut
échanger sur leurs problématique pour
charger du travail pour se rendre au
travail beaucoup de personnes qui sont
déjà en poste mais qui cherchent à se
rapprocher de 50 ans en Yvelines donc
c'est la bonne occasion pour nous du
fait qu'on soit situé sur 50 ans en
Yvelines de leur proposer un emploi tout
près de chez eux pour éviter les
transports et les temps à rallonge pour
aller travailler
[Musique]
un bilan plutôt positif parce qu'on a eu
on a eu des candidats qui nous ont
appelés en agence qui a envoyé des CV et
on a envoyé quelques candidats aussi en
entretient chez certains de nos clients
donc si ça peut vous intéresser pour
vous pour une personne de votre
entourage n'hésitez pas à postuler ça se
passe sur 50 ans Yvelines ok bon courage
au revoir monsieur on entretien demain